العديد من المشاهير حول العالم فضلوا
الابتعاد كليا او جزئيا عن وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي الحارس الاسباني فيكتور فالديز
الذي لعب في برشلونه لسنوات عده اغلق جميع
حساباته في مواقع التواصل عقبه اعتزاله
مصدرا لابتعادا الاضواء والتفرغ لعائلته
كذلك فان الفنانه الشهيره مايلي سايرس
حذفت عام 2018 جميع صور على انستغرام ثم
حذفت حسابها على المواقع مؤكده انها ترغب
باستراحه حتى تشعر انها افضل وحدث الممثل
كوميدي الامريكي
على انستغرام بعد ان عبر الناس عن اراء
سلبيه حول علاقته العاطفه والرومانسيه
مؤكدا انه لم يستطع التعامل مع التعليقات
السلبيه التي تلقاها من المعجبين الغاضبين
هو ايضا غدرت الممثله الامريكيه كليم ماري
تشانس انستقرام بعد شهور من المضايقه من
مشجع حرب النجوم العنصريين وتعليقاتهم
المسيئه لها والتي لم تستطع تحملها اما
المطرب الامريكي الشهير كانيويس كان لديه
تاريخ شهير مع الحذف والعوده حيث كررها
لعده مرات في مواجهه البعض ان ذلك كانت
محاولات لجذب النظر من قبله